Speaker 1: I told you last week that after
Joe Biden's absolutely brutal speech about
the Jan. six riot on the one year anniversary,
going right after Donald Trump for his role
in inciting those riots, Trump was so triggered.
Trump put out four consecutive statements
bizarre grammar, random capitalization.
Each statement basically just a repetition
of the previous really, really strange stuff.
Well, after that, Donald Trump was interviewed
by Joanne Owen is the even more radical right
wing network to Newsmax, which is already
a more radical right wing version of Fox News,
which is crazy.
So imagine where Newsmax is.
Newsmax went down to Florida.
It's relevant that this took place in Florida,
and you'll see why in a moment.
And Donald Trump just can't even string together
a single, coherent argument.
I mean, this is arguably the easiest interview
in history.
The interviewer was getting autographs from
Trump either before or after the interview.
She was pictured.
This is like a fan of Trump's just letting
him do whatever he wants.
And it's still humiliating, and Trump is still
saying any second now states are going to
be turned over to him.
He's talking about the 2020 election.
I know you're saying it's David, sir, it's
2022.
Trump is talking about flipping states in
the 2020 election.
Speaker 4: We ran a third world election and
things are coming out over the next couple
of days.
Maybe even today.
Speaker 1: We're always days away from the
Speaker 4: blockbuster one case.
I hear a very big stories coming out today
on the cheating, and numerous states are going
to be turned.
I don't know what they're going to do, but
it's going to show that they were won by me.
It's already shown right.
If you look at if you look at Arizona, if
you look at the findings in Arizona, is
Speaker 1: it sad at this point, guys?
That it's still the same talking points
Speaker 4: that's over, right?
We want it, and I'm going to go out there
next week.
We're making a speech, but if you look at
those findings, we won the state.
Speaker 1: So Trump did not win Arizona now.
Then Trump goes back to talking about the
size of his pathetic crowd.
He again is talking about crowd size.
I know it's 20 22.
Speaker 4: Everything was going beautifully.
And then the election got rigged and stolen
from the American people.
And by the way, that's the reason they went
in massive numbers.
They don't cover the numbers of people.
They always show the capital with a very small,
just a tiny percentage of the people that
were there.
They never show helicopter pictures of that
incredible crowd because it was the largest
crowd I've ever spoken before.
Speaker 1: I believe he's talking about the
Jan. six crowd never had a crowd.
Speaker 4: I've never seen a crowd that big.
Speaker 1: He's never even read or write.
He doesn't read if it's OK that it was
Speaker 4: massive, it was the real no.
I won't
Speaker 1: say.
Imagine the interview.
It was.
It was massive.
It was massive
Speaker 4: because it'll be a headline.
Oh, he exaggerated the number.
The real number was over that sacred number.
Yeah.
You know what?
That number was, right?
And sacred.
I don't even talk about that.
Speaker 1: It's kind of talking about it right
now.
Then Trump very strangely started saying the
media is censoring pictures of how big the
crowd was.
I mean, this is a very sick individual.
Speaker 4: But why do we have such a dishonest
press?
That's a question.
And why don't they show the real crowd right?
That was there on January six, the crowd of
people that was the biggest I've ever seen.
I haven't seen any.
You can hardly get a picture.
We're trying to find pictures.
They have.
They have censored, apparently pictures.
I don't want to show that crowd.
Speaker 1: It's all been completely it's you
can't go to Google Images and type in Trump
January six.
Oh, you can.
Oh oh, you get thousands of results.
Oh, sorry, the pictures are censored.
Now one nice moment.
Nice is when Trump continues to go after Mitch
McConnell and Mike Pence for the election
loss.
This is really great news because it shows
us the continued divide within the party,
which is what the left has.
The left is doing so poorly at putting together
a good strategy for 22.
We have to hope that their own division will
hurt them.
Trump going right after McConnell and Pence
here.
Take a look.
Speaker 2: What do you think?
What does the American public need to do in
order to not just feel secure but actually
secure our elections?
Speaker 4: Well, we have to get better people
than Mitch McConnell, who immediately gave
up.
And, you know, Mike Pence was.
It was sad because when you have more votes
than you have voters, you could send it back
to the legislatures, right?
Send it back.
Hey, excuse me, we have more votes and once
we do, check it out.
And by that time, they would have done something
because, as you know, they were starting to
get angry around that time.
They said, Wait a minute, we've been scammed.
There are protesters.
So that was disappointing with Mike and Mitch.
McConnell shouldn't have accepted it.
Speaker 1: Isn't that the best?
It is not common that a president so consistently
criticizes his own vice president and that
Mike failed us.
It was really disappointing.
Mike Pence couldn't have done anything, and
Mike Pence was right.
He knew it.
Then the topic came up of what actually happened
on January 6th, and Trump talked about all
of the love that day.
Take a look at this.
This is wild.
And it was
Speaker 3: cold that day.
People, people were very cold and weren't
trying to love that day.
Speaker 4: There was so much love out there
during the speech, but a tiny percentage and
they started walking to the Capitol.
In many cases, before he even spoke.
Speaker 1: Right?
It couldn't it.
If it was their idea, it wasn't even anything
Trump did.
Speaker 4: You know that was well known?
Yeah.
But they should show helicopter shots right
of the crowd not taken six hours before, like
they did with my inauguration.
You know, when they're
Speaker 1: still talking about the crowd size
in 2017, guys.
Speaker 4: So the inauguration hours before,
right?
And they talk about, Oh, not that great, because
I tell you what, it went down to the Washington
Monument and they know it just like they showed
the empty basketball arena and basketball.
Speaker 1: The guy is still talking about
the crowd size now.
The interview is completely unhinged.
What we're expecting at the rally in Arizona
on Saturday is probably more of this.
This is a very, very sick man.
But one of the really funny things is when
Trump was president, the FAA wouldn't allow
planes to fly over Mar a Lago.
You know, Mar-A-Lago down in Florida there,
it's near so many different airports in the
flight paths.
That's not happening anymore.
And multiple times.
I just love this multiple times during the
interview.
You hear planes right overhead and you can
see you can see and hear in Trump's voice
that he gets annoyed by it.
It is constant.
Now check this out.
Speaker 4: People respected us and they weren't
going to mess around.
You know, when you wake, you end up in wars.
And we were respected.
So one year ago, we were respected like probably
never before.
Speaker 1: One year ago, we were respected.
Now he can't even get the planes to stop flying
over Mar a Lago.
It happens again later in the interview.
And again, it just sort of seems to slightly
distract Trump.
You know, his ego is very bruised that now
planes are making noise over his house all
day.
Speaker 4: You do.
And what Owen does is so important and you
have a much bigger audience than people understand.
Thank you.
But you cover it better than anybody.
And we're talking about elections that are
broken, rigged.
Speaker 3: And you've been
Speaker 1: saying this, you were saying this.
All right.
So you guys get it just that.
Just another one of these insane interviews,
and they do not be confused.
This will continue.
Trump will continue meddling in or, you know,
depending on your perspective, meddling or
being involved in Republican politics until
the Republican Party doesn't allow him anymore
or until his health goes bad.
And he's not able to anymore, but he seems
as determined as ever to be involved.
So a humiliating own interview.
There's going to be more of this coming.
Make sure you're following us on Instagram
at David
Pakman show.